avete presente ragazzi quel gioco che è
una droga però ci gioco ogni tanto
perché è una droga
sto parlando di cluster track facciamo
cluster tra quelli attenti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj oggi
centrati su classe cioè che bello grazie
mille
e un gioco bellissimo e ogni tot vado
avanti perché ci facesse fare sempre un
miliardo di livelli erano rimasti
arrivavano arrivati al libro dello 6
vedete vi spiego tanto posso fare anche
ogni ogni tot mesi ma è bellissimo altro
giocatore di saltare da un camion
all'altro e non cascare per terra mi
hanno sbloccato anche il doppio salto
molto bene è il freeze track non mi
ricordo neanche come si usano l'avidità
ma chi se ne frega chi ne ha bisogno
jolo ecco forse non avrei un attimo
bisogno si può saltare su più di un
camion senza schiantarsi per terra molto
bene l'altro sono tanto che l'udc ha
talmente tanti camion che si è messo
allargare il gioco molto simpatica
questa cosa posso andare molto bene col
demonio perfetto uno potrebbe stare
anche su un camion per un'ora e mezza il
problema è che dopo un po si schiantano
da soli tipo
adesso se non mi muovo perdo quelli più
avanti in poche parole devo muovermi al
rav 12
questo è il mio concetto di usare
l'autostrada non so se faccio non so se
è giusto però alla scuola guida viene
insegnato esattamente questa cosa il
doppio stato dunque una fregatura perchè
tanto lo uso ma mi ammazzo uguale quindi
non serve a niente se non a far sembrare
le cose un po più semplici anche se non
lo sono per niente ma dovrei muovermi in
un attimo perfetto effetto perfetto
let's go away france periodo di averlo
fatto ci mette una vita in generale
livelli di classe frac perché sono
bellissimi ma sono allo stesso tempo un
casino ma nextlevel let's go la quale
dal traguardo easy peasy easy tua
sorella morta
let's go my friends let's go mamma mia
che problema ok che ha tratto la non ci
credo ho battuto un record incredibile
13 secondi questo non l'ha fatto nessuno
scommettete famiglie quanti l'hanno
fatto in 13 secondi quanti nessuno
vostra madre veramente una persona
orribile 59.600 64a niente male
next level ma sta gente gioca cluster
track certo che delle vostre vite non
sapevo che mi pare io compreso porca
vacca c'ero quasi bellissima st parte ce
la posso fare non sento e solo
difficilissimo ma ce la posso fare
[Musica]
bello porco demonio morto aspetta
aspetta aspetta parte è impossibile ma
qua voglio battere veramente record
mondiale ok ok dal record dei record
porca vacca peso la colonna in bocca
peccato era giusto se non fosse stato
per quello sarebbe stato tutto giusto
tipo adesso tipo adesso guardano record
voglio voglio vedere voglio vedere il
mio nome sui cartelloni pubblicitari di
tutto il mondo la mia faccia su dior
christian dior chi è questa plebaglia
che condivide il cartellone
pubblicitario come pensa se faccio un
livello lento quanto quanto mi mettono i
grossi che c'è un miliardesimo ho preso
un camion in faccia ma va tutto bene
va tutto bene poi tachipirina e passa
bravissimo bravissimo anche qua ma non
importa
avrò un naso orribile ho perso per un
millimetro questo gioco lo disinstallo
camion in faccia non fanno niente pro se
tocco il terreno moio logica tutto a
posto tranquilli tutto su perbene crasti
livelli c'è un piromane molto bene lui
ho preso in faccia e cartellone ma tutto
a posto
tu che mi sta andando decisamente bene
questa parte qua per quanto sia
abbastanza difficile
ormai sono abituato cosa sono sti cosi a
posto tranquilli tranquilli tutto
normale dov'è il cartellone
ahia ahia e c'è un po di casino non fa
niente li facciamo è veramente figo sto
gioco il problema è che madonna degli
ammazzarti per vincere tutti che prova a
lanciarmi di qua
uno che non abbiamo niente in contrario
l'effetto perfetto 22 secondi ottimo va
bene molto bene
ancora farc adorato la già quell'area
difficile cosa devo fare qua mi sa che
ho sbagliato strada
io mi butto a prescindere dentro le cose
tanto è un casino sto gioco è un
difficilissimo ma parco demonio è
difficilissima st parte
scusami a niente perché sbatto contro le
pareti e moglie ovviamente la roccia in
testa non mi fa niente ma le pareti si
tua madre fa schifo
bene tutto tranquillo dove devo andare
spiega mi dove devo andare lì dove devo
anche una roccia che mi va in faccia non
ci sono buchi per terra
io muoio ma forse domandare al contrario
ma come al contrario
ma cosa il contratto aiuto è
difficilissimo ho fatto è stato molto
difficile ma ce l'ho fatta
next level mio operato tutti questi
finora desert forest winter laser
medieval hansen
adesso abbiamo scifi che casino è il
whale sei file scusami la musica è
veramente un point
speriamo che lo sia anche il mondo
mi sono tolto da quei camion e qualcosa
mi dice che ho fatto veramente bene né
xlab sono un fenomeno di schiacciare e
sembra il simbolo di upson ingrosso solo
che ci sono dei camion in mezzo molto
bene molto bene occhi o quella roba lì
che non è che mi faccia impazzire però
magari ci fa sparare in alto hanno
sparato direttamente alle volte massimo
livello veramente va prema serio ma è
fighissimo
ho preso un cartellone in fascia 10 su
10 merita mi piace al video studio rosa
per il cartellone infatti bella suo
camion che badano adapter a non dovevo
andare di qua buono a sapersi
c'era un punto più avanti miche
bellissima st parte ct confonde tutto ha
forse devo rimanere attaccato un camion
che cade può essere
porco demonio morto dai che palle avrò
sbagliato tutti vicini questo urlo ma
non ne possa parte la sto rifacendo un
miliardo di volte difficilissimo perché
ciò l'abilità io c'ho l'abilità tipo
questa che si fresa non tutti i truck
quindi devo fare rimanere uno fermo li
fa era molto più facile il previsto
mi ero dimenticato di abilitare un
abilità legate al gioco di parole ma
così bene ce l'avessi avuto anche prima
avremo torco demonio cosa ho visto va
bene ma vai tranquillo e fai fai come ti
pare a the answer divertente che ho
fatto arrabbiare così tanto da farmi
inviare missili in bocca va bene ok ok
ok ok ok my friends ok my friends ok my
friends
ci siamo ci siamo vuota player con calma
e tranquilli a dover saltare per porre
lo schifo by edificio di crederci ancora
stavo sbagliando pensate ne mancano
ancora quattro laghi per finire
oddio cosa è successo erano tutti i
camion fermi questi porca vacca sta
cadendo calmi tutti calmi tutti calvin
harris perfetto lo vado cioè se non mi
stata una ragazza di lady gaga e non so
che cos'altro prova bel gol l'ho preso
va bene sta diventando veramente atroce
sta roba però importante continuare con
livelli bene così bene così
sono vivo e sto bene cosa è successo
vai vai vai fa il saltino pensa altino
festa tino fallo però non lo fa cosa è
successo ma porco demoni come fatta
schiantarmi ho fatto tutte le cose
giuste
c'è il bello che arriva giusto
arriva preciso incredibile stata
studiata del millimetro ai vai vai
fratello ai fratello vai è domandato
dove dove aiuto non capisco ma doveva
andare come li come ci arrivo lì come ci
arrivo lì sei che mi immagino il livello
dopo che una cagata
come al solito questo è difficilissimo
impossibile con i loro dopo una cagata
fammi vedere il livello cagata forza
fammelo vedere voglio vederlo questo
somatiche lo faccio in un tentativo solo
questo lo so io lo so già gli altri ci
hanno messi mille questo qua si emettono
perché tar anomalie livelli io lo so già
aiuti che me lo devi spiegare to buy
frate perfetto non ho capito eccolo l'ho
fatto subito e non solo fa soprattutto
un record incredibile prevedere tra i
primi 10 mila
abbiamo fatto anche livello scifi fosse
mai steam punk lo faccia non lo facciamo
neanche vederla voglia prossimo ottobre
i ragazzi però che vi sia piaciuto sono
contentissimo ogni tanto di portare
cluster frac perché molto simpatico e mi
piace esco che una mezza crisi di nervi
ma vabbè chissenefrega se proprio vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi con se il servizio
fosse un momento è un mi piace anche al
riso condito da descrizione senza
presidi schede ci vediamo allora seguito
da ragazzi
[Musica]